IN FACT, BACK IN THE 1970S, I
HOSTED-- IF I MAY SAY SO
MYSELF-- ONE OF THE HIPPEST TALK
SHOWS ON UHF.
IF YOU COULD GET THE RECEPTION,
IT WAS AWESOME.
WE ACTUALLY ADDRESSED THIS VERY
TOPIC.
YOU'LL SEE HOW DIFFERENTLY WE
HANDLED PARENTING BACK THEN.
I DON'T REMEMBER EXACTLY WHAT I
SAID, BUT I REMEMBER IT WAS
GOOD.
TAKE A LOOK.
BEFORE WE BRING OUT OUR FIRST
GET, LOLA, DIG THIS, SATURDAY,
MY WIFE AND I HOSTED OUR MONTHLY
BARBECUE.
THANKS FOR ALL THE VIEWERS WHO
CAME OUT AND JOINED US.
IT'S REALLY A GREAT WAY TO
MINGLE, MEET PEOPLE.
NOTHING LIKE BURGERS, DOGS AND
WIFE SWAPPING.
DIG THIS.
I LET MY YOUNGEST SON
TUTANKHAMEN LIGHT THE BARBECUE.
IT'S A TRADITION WHEN A BOY
TURNS FOUR AND BECOMES A MAN.
THE FIRE GOT A LITTLE OUT OF
HAND, THE FUZZ SHOWS UP AND I
HAD TO BEAT THE CRAP OUT OF
TUTANKHAMEN
SO FAR, SO GOOD.
TONIGHT'S TOPIC IS CHILD
DISCIPLINE-- HOW FAR SHOULD YOU
GO?
AS A DAD, I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING YOU COULD TELL
YOUR KID IS SHUT THE ( BLEEP )
UP.
( LAUGHTER )
I CAN'T THINK OF A BETTER ROLE
MODEL THAN FRED G. STANFORD. G
STANDS FOR "GET MY BELT"
I ACKNOWLEGE THIS MIGHT JUST BE
A JIVE TURKEY ISSUE, I GET THAT
THERE ARE ALL KIND OF WAYS TO
DISCIPLINE A KID.
YOU THROW A BOOK AT THE BACK OF
THE KID'S HEAD.
THAT WILL GET THEIR ATTENTION.
AFTER YOU'VE GOTTEN THEIR
ATTENTION, THEY CAN READ THE
BOOK.
DIG THAT.